hello my name is Alan Strickland
Williams and I'm going to tell you 11
jokes
first off Flo about me I live my life by
one simple rule you guys work hard play
hard whether I'm at the office or just
hanging out with friends I always have a
boner one thing I like to do is I like
to get really high and then I like to go
on Google Maps and I like to go to that
Street View and just drive
see what's out there
ever hear that old tale about how a kid
gets caught smoking a cigarette
so his old man makes him smoke a whole
carton of cigarettes I hope that as
society progresses and marijuana becomes
legal everywhere one day there's a kid
who's like yeah my old man caught me
smoking a joint so then he made me smoke
whole carton of joints now I'm just the
chillest dude ever and everybody likes
me
anyone's planning on drinking later
tonight just keep this in mind beer
before liquor never been sicker red wine
before bourbon I am a full-blown
alcoholic
if you ever out at a restaurant some of
your with might say hey let's order a
family-style I always assume that means
we go to our separate rooms and eat in
total silence I feel pretty comfortable
here I'm going to come right out and say
it I'm a proud member of the LGBT
community right
I'm loving God big-time
hanging up the big guy
my girlfriend caught me masturbating she
set up one of those traps in the woods
[Laughter]
[Applause]
do you guys think that Sigmund Freud
came up with all that psychology stuff
because one time he accidentally said he
wanted to have sex with his mom I was
like oh I can't wait to go home and have
sex with my mom me my wife everybody
looked at him weird
he was like everybody wants to have sex
with their mom
a lot of times guys will nickname their
penis I did this when my penis is hard I
call it the rock and when it's flaccid
I call it Dwayne Johnson do a quick
impression for you guys this is an
impression of Jesus Christ ordering at a
wine bar I'll just have a water I'll
leave you with this
I would never name my kid jr. I think
there's something kind of cruel about
that but I would name him the return of
Alan Strickland Williams
[Applause]
you